voorzitter president lagarde
sinds eind jaren 2000 probeert de europese
centrale bank voor god te spelen
door geld te drukken
zoals het brood
uit de hemel kwam
president lagarde
de kerndoelstelling van uw ecb is prijsstabiliteit
maar uw instelling houdt zich bezig met van alles
het redden van hoge schuldenlanden
slechte leningen opkopen
klimaatverandering en 1 digitale euro
waar niemand om heeft gevraagd
maar van de
grote economische uitdagingen waarmee de bevolking
wordt geconfronteerd
inflatie huisvesting
hoge staatsschulden
lage economische groei
licht veel van de oorsprong in Frankfurt
kerninflatie gaat omlaag
maar is nog steeds niet onder controle
de verloren koopkracht van de afgelopen jaren
krijgen de mensen
nooit meer terug
president lagarde
het is belangrijk dat u zich beperkt tot uw kerntaak
het is tijd om de beest terug in De Kooi te stoppen
alleen dan kan de ecb het vertrouwen van de mensen
terugwinnen